on this week's show our no money down
deals actually possible in the news
Britain is on track for a recession and
we're answering all your prophecy
related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends iowa's leads I'm
Alistair Cunningham and welcome to the
property investors podcast a question
that we get asked a lot yeah
like literally I can't go about two
minutes about someone coming up to me
space at an event ya know just in
general I can't I can't go two seconds
without happening ya know but a lot of
people say our are no money down deals
possible and I mean you know Grant
Cardone obviously says that they're not
you know no me doubt is aa possible that
people say they are other people aren't
sure so we thought we would clearing up
once and for all I think it needs
clarification is our no money down deals
possible first of all when people say no
money down deals you're gonna look at
what they are what their digs at Lee are
they talking about yeah because you know
immediately the thing that comes to mind
is you're going to mister you know you
can't go into an estate agent and go I
want to buy that house and I want to put
down zero deposit boom that is not
possible
yep not possible that would be cool
though wouldn't it would be cool yeah I
love that one please and I'm not paying
you for it yep understand I'd be banging
it's not a pin law it's not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen and the other
thing that you've got to understand is
and when you're purchasing any property
there is always money involved yep
always money involved so it's nice to
bear in mind so it doesn't happy your
money but it's always money involved
this is true so if that means I mean
we're in a program called never use your
own money again yeah they're use your
own money
again no never use money again yeah
never use money again that is a
different program I didn't never been on
that one
no no bus there's never use your own
money again now so that's the first
thing so let's have a look at the
different strategies because yes it's
possible to make money from property
without using any money so let's see how
we could do that and the fact that
samuel has done the financial freedom
challenges kind of proves that it works
he goes like with no money he gets deals
so it proves it works but let's have a
look at different strategies so first
strategy that you could use to do a
no-money-down deal is rent to rent yeah
so do you wanna eloquently eloquently
claim is this why I shouldn't be doing
is what you're doing it eloquently
explained what rental rent is yeah sure
man rent rent is where you take a
property from an owner and you with
permission to let it out you take it off
them on a different contract and then
you rent out it's that simple
okay cool so normally obviously when you
rent when you rent a property you rent
it out to live in it you've become when
you rent or do you become a tenant
we've rent to rent you're renting it but
then rather than living in it you're
renting it out again and you make your
money by renting it out for higher than
you're renting it for yeah so I wrapped
here's the middle map good strategies
rent to rent and then convert it into a
hit you more
so we've just sorted one of them out
we've just secured one so yeah which
we're making around about what fifteen
hundred quid profit probably closer to a
grand but yeah so and guess what no
money down people will ask ok owns how
you can get the property but how is it a
no money down deal because like for
example if you're gonna rent it as a
HMOs surely you've got to convert it
into a HMO so how does that work so ok
so you could do a joint venture with
somebody that has got the money so I
know many people that have not got the
money but they've got the tank so they
go out and they find deals and they
secure the deals and then they partner
up with somebody who's who can maybe
invest three or four thousand pounds now
looking at a difference because
obviously you can always borrow money
but can you do a rent to rent deal no
money down let's look at the cost in
them because the truth is is you can you
have done them but normally there are
some small cost yeah yeah so you've got
deposit is one okay then you need to
learn to negotiate better I'm not saying
that you don't have to everytime let's
go through the cost I mean look at why
could be naughty got a deposit yeah
you've got the making it ready to rent
out costs yeah whatever whatever that
might there and then you've got legal
costs yeah that's that's probably about
it yeah yeah sometimes three four
thousand pound yeah yeah
so for the Hat for the property that
we're talking about there'll be some
costs though a the conversion costs yep
there's no deposit no negotiating no
deposit I said there'll be the cost the
contract how much well if you use on
this one we don't need to use our we
don't need to use this list of the
contract because it's already been
sorted out and we've got our we've got
we've got a very good contract we use so
the cost for comparison and this one's
going to be a couple of thousand pound
it needs a couple of fire doors fin it's
a brand new property so you just need
some fire doors cool a couple of
thousand pound yeah now if you were
gonna rent it out a service
accommodation yeah which is the other
strategy you use for enter an and it was
already furnished to a high standard you
don't need to do any conversion costs I
think fire doors in fact I was bit linen
things you do fire doors but you need to
put like you need to prep it better
linen bit of air nice bedding all that
stuff and but but it might be fully foot
like he can you can rent you I have
rented one bit was just I don't need to
do anything
it was totally good to go so you can
negotiate no deposit no deposit no the
way I do it is look you got to get
creative here if you want to get a no
money down or no money down sort of
secured dealing you weren't even ago she
had no deposit you can ask it your hands
Dori do you know I mean you can't have
it all your own way so you can't have no
deposit and then expect it to be an
immaculate property so the way I've done
it in the past was we negotiated on our
property I secured in Oxford where the
property needed he was in the middle
decorate in it so I paint in the rooms
and just just tartan and place up a
little bit so I negotiated that we would
finish the decoration and but we weren't
going to pay they wanted two months
deposit this was before tenant P man so
he wanted two months deposit which would
to be about three grand and he wrote a
three months we going deposit plus the
first month's rent upfront
yeah so you wanted four and a half
thousand pound near they were there
about and I said look I'll come in I'll
they create the house to a high standard
we are going to dress at all that sort
of we're going to make it look nice but
you don't and you don't have to do
anymore of this work we will do all now
he agreed to that but I said because
we're going to that we'd only be paying
a deposit because we're gonna be invest
in your property and he was fine with
that and he did it be negotiated are no
deposit we also negotiated a two-week
rent-free period so I got the keys to
that property with no deposit and I had
two weeks before I had to start paying
rent now the cost for me to finish the
decoration was my time because he'd
already bought all the paints materials
so ok I'm not gonna say it was a 100%
normally done deal like I'm talking like
a hundred quid for a few bits of
paintbrushes and that from being cute as
opposed to I didn't have to buy the
paint cuz he bought it all and it was my
time so if you factor in my time then
yes there's a course but like I say in
the early days when you're looking for
normal stuff you're gonna have to get
your hands dirty if you want to get
these normal don't deals but you're
talking I mean you can always negotiate
but you're talking very very low money
down and I know people that got credit
cards and then they've so they've gone
and got a credit card to three grand
limit favoured a little bits and pieces
there need got the rent in Hadley partly
because yeah and even some of the small
cost that you do you do be a credit card
so not your money as a parent card
companies money so if you do that for
example look there's always money
involved so I understand what people say
there's no such thing as I made a deal
because yet there's always money going
money involved but what you can do is
certain strategies regiment being one of
them you can limit that right right down
to just their I mean there's and then
you can either just put the mode out
you've got a couple of ground or you can
use someone else's money or you can use
a credit card right I agree with you
completely right but I am sick and tired
of hearing this people from people say
that it's not normally don't is you can
do no money down deals we you do not
have got a penny of your money into it I
know this cuz I've done it and I know
people that have done it so if you're
one of them people seen you can't do it
you're right you can't do it but many
people are doing it
get creative man you're in business this
is business yeah this is not hoppy start
treating it like a business utilize your
expense you utilize how you expend your
money
stop getting credit cards for rubbish
holidays get credit card and put it into
business use a loan if you get a loan
use it for business as opposed to buying
a new car or buying some nice new phones
whatever start getting using your
lending wisely now I know so many people
that have got credit cards for this
Peter or theirs that we just said got a
credit card used it for the deposits
whatever else and then Peter offer them
in the rank starts coming in me and yes
it's not a normally done deal because
money is involved but it doesn't have to
be your money now the only people that
ever say well you've got to put money
into it and you have to put money in
it's not knowing down that generally
broke that generally broke people that
have got a broke mindset if you want to
be successful in business you have to
get creative and you have to start
thinking outside the box because
unfortunately in their shoes think
outside the box and they should get
creative you're never going to be
successful so get creative utilize
credit cards you utilize loans who do
you know who's got money who do you know
will lend you three four thousand pounds
to start that rent rent deal on are even
if you clip 75% of the rent and they get
twenty five percent you all know
somebody or you can all raise funding
because trust me most people when you
want to get a new car they'll find
funding when they want to get a new
phone they'll find funding when they
want to get a new cut a new iPad or a
new computer they'll fund it somehow
start thinking about how you're funding
things and start stop funding the
correct things as Robert Kiyosaki says
assets not liabilities buy assets not
liabilities we actually which will be
quite relevant right now if you can put
a limb we did a show dimly about good
diverses bad day a while ago so binge do
if you if you want to if you're unsure
what he's saying maybe like now finish
this episode first and go and watch that
one
it's annoying we live in an age we're on
an age today where it's never been
easier to borrow money it's never been
easier man hmm it's so easy it bore
money so just we went to rent that's cut
was so again we do loss training on rent
to rent and that's the crash course we
all know how to actually do that but
they go no money down deal right next
and I thought will do one each you can
talk about these options yep I'll talk
about Bharathiraja vine
yeah yeah okay strategy so lease options
lease option is a but you you agreed to
buy in a period of time but you take
control of it now so yes you don't own
it until you've completed the purchase
and five seven ten years time however
long you agree but you you get honest
you get control of it now I've done
several of these all of them one long
one
very true story one of them was no money
down no deposit and six months rent-free
six months with no option payments
because the property didn't need a
little bit of work and I just done that
work but I didn't have to pay rent and
but there was absolutely no money
involved in getting the keys to that
property yes I had to put a lot of my
money in to get it converted but for me
to get the keys in my hand was no money
and you could have rented it out in its
bad condition no it wasn't bad you
wanted I wanted to get more rent so I
converted it to HMO because it's
mortgage free and I wanted to get more
rain out of it so I compared them to how
much you put it all together so
initially it was normally down to me
I put the legal fees which was a
thousand pound onto my credit card no
money to me it was money to mark
MasterCard right they paid it from me
and then that was it then there wasn't I
got the keys after paying legal fees and
then six months later I started Pina a
lease payment to them every month about
260 pound and but the thing is right is
that you say it's a basically MasterCard
paid it for you yeah but you didn't pay
MasterCard back no I didn't tenants it
paid MasterCard back because the Ted
started paying you rent from normally
you put down which they paid off your
master code I have tenants within three
months so I wasn't paying rent to the
the I wasn't been a lease payment to the
vendor for three months a six months soy
but my tenants moved in within three
months and they started paying me rent
so I built up a buffer that buffer paid
the MasterCard off that I used to do the
refurb work and the the rest is now off
so I'm still a little bit with regards
because I because I chose to do as our
HMO and not a single lay I could've done
as a single it made maybe two hundred
and fifty pound a month but I do it as I
hate you more I make 7-under pen a month
so I would like do not mean that five
hundred per month
make him that she's come back to pee the
mascot off they paid four grand for the
refurb so come on man it's no money down
deals the lease options nearby
refurbished refinance I give an example
of what of one I did so I've got a
property I had to put 30 grand into it
okay I actually as a joint venture so we
went halves so the sixth man all in all
together okay we've got 30 grand each
but the deal was he did the work on the
property yeah I borrow the 30 grand all
right so no money don't owe me down no
work I'd do anything at all he
approached me with a deal saying you've
got 30 grand in I'll do the work so I
did nothing
yeah he did all the work up he's a
little remortgage everything he gave me
130 grand back I gave it back I had 17
and a half grand extra so I paid them
off with their interest I made money
from it I know you you you put 30 grand
and you at forty seven thousand five
hundred back yeah and now I own well I
don't own because they got mortgages but
I yeah but I've got they've got
mortgages on but I've got a deposit kind
of I've got money tied up in two
apartments because there was for me at
two each so where are they they are it's
in the Midlands okay unfortunately don't
hold that against them me down deal
borrow firmly finance you put your money
into pulling money back out but you
don't put your money in or someone
else's money in and then you pull their
money back out it literally cost me
nothing yeah we do want to get now so
we're building some apartments again we
I'm not I'm not doing the work I'm
putting the money and the money's coming
back out again now as it happens I'm
using my own money
but if I borrowed money it'll be the
same principle be not wouldn't if you if
you can be a situation where you've got
access to access to money and this
doesn't money if you're putting money in
pulling the money out again it it almost
feels like a no money down deal because
you're pulling money back out again so
you're not leaving any money in the deal
yeah but that if it's your money then
obviously not normally them because
you've got to put the cash though the
one I just talked about with a thirty
grand that wasn't much no no no we've
talked about in the past and it's a
great little deal and it's like infant
Luke this is business
treat it like a business and if you
treat it like a business and you start
taking it seriously you'll get a serious
result
and I said this a minute ago it's
generally the people that say it's not
possible or the people that are never
gonna be successful the people that
broke because they get one horrid oh and
they stop you get one they get to the
first obstacle and they don't go for it
because in their head that their heads
telling them out their head is taking
them out the game there are as many
people say that little that little
person sat on the shoulder seen it's not
possible it's not possible
yeah maybe not for you but it's for many
people yeah I'd say rent rent was the
closest all these options because both
of those content to keep it in for no
money there's normally some little bits
and pieces yeah if you can't drag
together a thousand pounds yeah I'm just
gonna say if this is gonna go against a
lot but in fairness if you cannot get a
couple thousand pound together its
property even for you do you not I mean
yeah but so ya know me down deals yes
they are possible but there's always
money involved just somebody great yeah
but it could be very very small and you
can do it cleverly and use a credit card
or something you this is the crucial
thing we're gonna finish on you do not
need any money in your bank account to
start making money from property nope
100 times we fact right it's now time
for this
[Music]
okay so in the news today Conte a lot of
articles at the minute Britain is on
track for recession a lot of the sectors
are slowing down in particular the
services sector slowed down by around
eighty percent of GDP so sloth slowdown
in growth which is reason making alarm
bells raised for all the the big hairs
and it's indication that recession is
round the corner so what do we think
about that a lot of people are talking
about recession it was looming and they
reckoned mid 2020 don't name recession
is gonna be hitting do the thing is
suppose for me I'm so used to it I
started my business in 2001 was a big
recession it's about that it doesn't
mean hey about tonight yeah same as I
got married that year I have my own
house it's like so I'm like really going
for it through that
so for me I'm cry so used to it it's
like yeah we've been in recession we've
been out of recession
it never really affects me I've done
property investing in it I've done it
out of it every year I'm doing like this
no matter what the economy does Sammy
winters this you creates your own your
own economy and I believe that so for me
look obviously we don't want a recession
but there's always new recessions after
the recession becomes expansion after
expansion comes recession he goes like
that doesn't it's interesting that you
during 2008 you were doing well and your
businesses were gone what I was doing
well but that's when I started yes
that's when I
so I started I had a business I died in
2007 and I hit recession 2008 2008 was
my best year
so when recession hit 2008 and 2009 with
my best two years in that business like
by some as well the one they ran so they
everyone goes I'm at recession and I
don't know if it's coming or not who
does I think it hits certain businesses
yeah I don't know if it's coming or not
we don't know and as our a savvy
property investor you make money
Invitational out recession you make
money when the commies up economy's down
you can make more when the economy's
down
yeah think of the bargains you may begin
now yes if people are going to be losing
properties and things that aren't then
it's it's hard but come on this is this
is business I don't know it just forces
you to be good
yeah just zoom in expansion any idiot
can make money yeah that's the truth
right any you know when everyone's doing
well and they're in the recession you
see who the good people at look it's
what it is if it comes then just have to
make sure you're educated make sure
you're getting creative and look after
your own business mind your own business
look after yourself mind your business
don't worry about everyone else's
businessmen you own make sure you're
doing the right things get creative get
educated and keep growing kick you have
it seem good and you'll be fine get good
habits keep growing and push away
through that recession awesome all right
it's now time for this okay so this
department show where we answer your
questions so if you want a question
answered you can comment on YouTube you
know we'll try and get through some of
them and also if you join the Facebook
group of property investors with Samuel
Leeds we do sort of Facebook lives now
we're include you ask questions then we
sort of scroll for this that's where
we're at right now so I like this
question okay I like this question so
we're gonna answer on the cat three okay
let me read the question first but don't
say so oh I see you got a same answer hi
guys
I'm bad set off for the crash course
tomorrow a nice 4-hour Drive let's do
this awesome this is Brad heart by the
way Brad the Hitman Hart my question is
if you only could use one property
strategy for the rest of your career
yeah what would it be these are your
options a buy refurbished refinance this
is so relevant to today's show yeah
these are the three strategies we talked
about well Brad you're amazing
big rent to Renton or see at least
option agreements or so the three gonna
answer a three your answer on three
pants yeah boom they go Brad buy a box
right next question can I let a four-bed
property in Leeds as a multi let if it's
already an article for area well it
depends on the property so this is this
there's two ways that you could do it
mostly no but here are the two ways you
get around it number one if that
property had already been used as a HMO
then you have something called
grandfather rights and you can or number
two you could apply for planning
permission to the council and say hey
can I use this property as a for bed and
chances are dependent how long's leads
me ask before a couple of years now I
believe and it's not leaders not all
aren't for some ways it's there's only
certain areas and leads so so you ever
see it's in an article for area it's
fine so speed to the council said yet
hands they might yeah if like HMOs are
decreased its have decreased in that
area yeah and there's a clever they have
like are a percentage or that they have
to go to school got that day to wait to
the pitch amorphous mmm there you go
Kyle if you want to have a go on YouTube
get as prep to the next question he go
so Kyle I'm sure he's asked to question
me folks we weren't sure whether it was
gin org in but we'll go gin Kyle gin any
advice on securing a business loan as
approach to raising Kashmir investors
pros and cons is the these questions
designed for this show stock the new me
down deal so business loans as opposed
to raising cash from investors pros and
cons of each will be handy raising a
business lon
as opposed to reason cash from investors
right firstly it's very unlikely a band
a bank will lend you money
investable to invest in property unless
it's on a mortgage it's very unlikely
so mmm I've got advice but I wouldn't do
i wouldn't publicize him just because
the depends for you what you're gonna
use that money for and what you're going
to tell them you're gonna use it for
obviously that breaks Bank and Bank and
rules bar I know in the past what I've
done this is what I've done this is not
what I'm recommending you do so just
just remember that this is what I've
done I'm not that's what I've done
not anybody else so I needed to borrow
some money in my own business and but I
knew that if I went through the business
team the business banking team it would
take forever and they'd want to see
business plans he'd want to see this
they want to see that and everything
else so I just i rung them up i rung up
the bank at IHS PC and said I would like
to borrow some money because I needed to
do some bring some renovations to my
house and they lent me the money I then
use that for my business
and so look I'm not saying that's right
wait do it that's what I done shoot me
there and if you want a talk with a cure
that's why I done because I'm sorry and
I'm creative it's not legal advice do
what you want to do but that's why I
done so just to clarify that's not legal
advice is that legal advice or or I'm
not telling you to do that and it's
against all bank and regulations however
so now you know exactly what our stare
tells you to do you can know and do it
is legal advice so maximilien hanson
brooks says how to rest your release
option through an estate agent with
difficulty oh you can you can but you
need to make sure that their state agent
is on your side and that you know you're
not what they know you like what is an
estate agent one all right they want to
sell a house and they want to get their
fee that's all they want so if you can
agree to do a purchase even though it's
a delayed purchase or a lease option and
the stage and still gets paid their fee
it's like they're gonna work with you
and I say this a lot when you have an
area you should know all their state
agents and you should get friendly with
some of them because they'll be your
best form of deal sauce so they'll bring
new deals aren't even on the market yet
because they're dealing with a the the
vendors all the time so you just need to
get out there and meet a state agent get
to know them and tell them what you're
looking for and tell them that if they
if they bring you the deal you'll still
pay their fee they're not gonna lose out
you're not going to cut them out of the
deal so yeah that's that's one way I
would do it cool all right next
Carla so cliff could you call the
differences between Si and holiday let's
please I'm just trying to have my wrap
my
head around the idea oh wait you cover
that one that's your special especially
older Lexi's like it's like a type of
essay isn't it yeah so is there's not
there's not a lot of difference essay is
just a little bit broader cuz obviously
it would include other things so for
example renting a room in a house or
renting an apartment for a night which
obviously doesn't really a holiday let
but yeah there's not it's not a massive
there's not a massive difference holiday
that's just a type of serviced
accommodation oh yeah yes I agree with
it's just a different sort strategy into
like - you love it by the beach
somewhere ever and here's one that's
just come up from sm do you prefer
interest only mortgages with product
fees and lower rates or without product
fees but higher rates
do you always add the product fees alone
amount anyhow it would much appreciate
it so he's obviously looking at
mortgages do you add all the fees into
the amount I just do whatever whatever
it's like wait burial it was the
cheapest month payment oh yeah whatever
less normally less money less but as
long as its life makes sense the less
money down is mine so yeah and I would
always again speak to a mortgage broker
this is there this is their back and but
i all my mortgages are interest only and
i go for it i wanted to put as little
deposit down as possible and that
includes fees things that are so i want
to keep that as low as possible and if
that means adding the fees to the end of
the lawn ends will be it why does it
alastair have two glasses yeah oh what a
reason last week it was last week when
it we had two one was half empty was
last week it was the week before and the
week before that because somebody bought
me a glass and some didn't take it away
as simple as that
simple answer can you believe that these
days when they bring you a drink that
take away your roommate that's the booze
they were both had water in their both
half full oh well yeah I know why it is
I can remember it's because it's good
this - you're an optimist because you
didn't see the half-empty no they're
both half-full I feel yeah well I told
you suppose I asked me so the reason was
was because Nick made him a glass of
water left it on the table but then
Danielle made him one before he came in
so he came in with a glass of water
and put it down on the table yeah and
then he just randomly was drinking for
both of them which is like you know
because he wanted them both to be half
full
yep puffle so there's a here's another
question
and our phone that's quite funny this
question from masked financial hero is
it me or anguish say he is moving into
London yeah yeah we are yeah a complete
ptosis right anymore okay right that's
one CSH guitars so good video but would
you not buy your own property on a
residential mortgage minute deposit is
about tempting not 25 if it's your first
one
yeah but as a residential yeah so as a
residential mortgage yeah you can get
mortgages up to like a 90 percent LTV so
yeah you don't have to 10% deposit and
so that's good
so yeah you wouldn't you wouldn't need
to put a 25 percent deposit unless you
wanted to many people do you can choose
your deposit really but the most you'll
get length is up to I think 90% I don't
think there's any higher than that in
the UK it's not like in pre 2008 when
you can get 110 percent we're back next
Saturday at 7 p.m. do not forget to
check us out and subscribe to us on
whatever platform you're watching this
on or if you're listening Oh that'd be
great as well see you next week guys see
you guys
[Applause]
you
[Applause]